sur le sol de la cuisine en disant :
« Je pense que vous devez avoir besoin de nourriture par ici. »
(Rires)
La troisième semaine, les célébrités -- Entertainment Tonight,
Access Hollywood.
La quatrième semaine, l'international -- la BBC, la radio irlandaise.
Est-ce que vous avez vu « Lost in Translation » ?
Mon mari a fait de la télévision japonaise.
C'était intéressant.
(Rires)
Et toutes ces vidéos.
La vidéo du glacier de Paul Bissonnette : incroyable.
Et celle des Sœurs de la Rédemption à Dublin ?
Qui l'a vue ?
C'est absolument fantastique.
Justin Timberlake.
C'est à ce moment-là que nous avons eu des célébrités de premier plan.
Je regarde mes messages et j'en vois un
de ma sœur : « JT ! JT ! »
Angela Merkel, la chancelière allemande.
Incroyable.
Et les patients du SLA,
savez-vous lesquels sont leurs préférées, à eux et à leurs familles ?
Toutes.
Parce que cette maladie rare mal comprise et sous-financée,
ils ont vu les gens dire encore et encore : « SLA, SLA. »
C'était incroyable.
Et ces personnes négatives,
parlons un peu de statistiques.
L'Association du SLA,
ils pensent que d'ici à la fin de l'année, il y aura 160 millions de dollars.
Le SLA TDI à Cambridge,
ils ont récolté trois millions de dollars.
Devinez quoi.
Ils ont eu un essai clinique pour un médicament qu'ils ont développé.
Il était parti pour trois ans de recherche de financement.
Deux mois.
Cela commence dans deux mois.
(Applaudissements)
Et d'après Youtube,
plus de 150 pays ont posté des Ice Bucket Challenge.
Et Facebook, 2,5 millions de vidéos,
et j'ai vécu la super aventure
de visiter le campus de Facebook la semaine dernière.
Je leur ai dit : « Je savais à quoi cela ressemblait de chez moi.
Je n'avais aucune idée de ce à quoi cela ressemblait ici. »
Tout ce qu'elle a dit était : « A rester bouche-bée. »
Et la vidéo préférée de ma famille ?
Celle de Bill Gates.
Parce que le soir du diagnostic de Pete,
il nous a dit qu'il amènerait le SLA devant des philanthropes comme Bill Gates,
et il l'a fait.
But numéro 1 : fait.
Maintenant, allons-y pour le traitement et le remède.
(Applaudissements)
Après toute cette glace,
nous savons que cela était bien plus
que de simplement se renverser des seaux d'eau glacée sur la tête,
et j'aimerais vous quitter
sur quelques choses dont j'aimerais que vous vous souveniez.
La première chose est,
chaque matin lorsque vous vous réveillez,
vous pouvez choisir de vivre votre journée de façon positive.
Est-ce que l'un d'entre vous m'en voudrait
si chaque jour je me mettais
en position fœtale et me cachait sous les couvertures ?
Non, je ne pense pas que qui que ce soit m'en voudrait,
mais Pete nous a inspirés à nous réveiller
chaque matin et à être positifs et proactifs.
En fait, j'ai dû laisser tomber des groupes de soutien
parce que tout le monde là-bas disait
qu'ils étaient atteints de SLA
en entretenant leur pelouse avec des engrais chimiques,
j'étais là : « Je n'y crois pas »
mais je devais m'éloigner de la négativité.
La seconde chose sur laquelle je voudrais vous quitter
est que la personne au centre du défi
doit avoir la force mentale
de se sortir de là.
Pete continue à aller voir des matchs de baseball
et il s'assoie toujours sur le banc de touche avec ses équipiers,
et il accroche sa poche de nutriment sur les cages.
Vous verrez les gamins, là-haut l'accrocher.
« Pete, c'est bon ? » « Ouais. »
Et ensuite ils le mettent dans son estomac.
Parce qu'il veut qu'ils voient ce que c'est vraiment,
et qu'il n'abandonnera jamais.
La troisième chose sur laquelle j'aimerais vous quitter :
si vous traversez un jour une situation
que vous percevez comme inacceptable,
je veux que vous creusiez aussi profond que vous le pouvez
que vous cherchiez votre meilleure maman ours
et que vous y alliez.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Je sais que je dépasse le temps imparti, mais je dois vous quitter là-dessus :
les cadeaux que mon fils m'a offerts.
J'ai eu l'honneur d'être
la mère de Pete Frates
pendant 29 ans.
Pete Frates a inspiré et dirigé durant sa vie entière.
Il a fait preuve de gentillesse,
et toute cette gentillesse est revenue vers lui.
Il est sur Terre actuellement et il sait pourquoi il y est.
Quel cadeau.
La seconde chose que mon fils m'a donnée
est qu'il m'a donné la mission de ma vie.
Maintenant je sais pourquoi je suis ici.
Je vais sauver mon fils,
et si cela n'arrive pas à temps pour lui,
je vais travailler pour qu'aucune autre mère
n'ait à traverser ce que je traverse.
La troisième et dernière chose, mais pas la moins importante
que mon fils m'ait offerte,
comme un point d'exclamation
à ce merveilleux mois
d'août 2014 :
cette petite amie qu'il est allé chercher le soir de son diagnostic est sa femme,
et Pete et Julie m'ont donné ma petite-fille, Lucy Fitzgerald Frates.
Lucy Fitzgerald Frates est arrivée avec deux semaines d'avance
comme point d'exclamation
le 31 août 2014.
Et donc --
(Applaudissements) --
Laissez-moi vous quitter sur les mots inspirés de Pete
qu'il utiliserait devant ses camarades de classe, collègues et équipiers.
Soyez passionnés.
Soyez vrais.
Travaillez dur.
Et n'oubliez pas d'être géniaux.
Merci. (Applaudissements)